vie quotidienne et risques sanitaires
des parents d'élèves d'une école de
marseille ont demandé qu on coupe une
des grandes antennes de téléphonie
mobile installées sur le toit du
bâtiment parce qu'ils sont inquiets
en quête de michaël darmon et benoît
jourdain désactivé mais pas démonté
cette antenne installée par un opérateur
de téléphone mobile sur le toit de cette
école de marseille attire les foudres
des parents d'élèves
ces derniers craignent les effets des
rayons magnétique et des ondes sur les
enfants alors pendant plusieurs semaines
ils ont occupé l'école manifester la
mairie vient de demander à l'opérateur
de débrancher l'antenne pour l'instant
sur le toit d'une école ça paraît pas
quand même la noix le plus approprié
pour vous reposer l'inde dont on ne
connaît pas les effets mon moi je n'ai
pas personnellement de connaissances sur
des idées mais il ya quand même des
études qui sommes fait car cette petite
guerre des antennes en cache une autre
celle des expertises pour l'instant
celle que met en avant les opérateurs
vont tous dans le même sens pas de
danger pour la santé publique
sauf que les parents restent sceptiques
la mairie veut rassurer à la fois les
habitants et les opérateurs
elle prend donc une attitude politique
une vie vous baignons dans les champs
électromagnétiques largement supérieurs
à ceux des antennes mais les gens
veulent aussi savoir
ils veulent pouvoir décider entre le
risque subi et actuellement ils ont
l'impression de le subir
et le risque choisi je rappelle que le
chant donné par un autre téléphone
portable est supérieur au chant produit
par un relais dentelle de concertation
sont prévues en met en joie car la
colère monte contre les antennes mobiles
une trentaine de communes en france sont
interdits aux opérateurs d'installer
leur antenne à moins de 300 mètres des
habitations à marseille trois autres
écoles servent de base relais c'est dire
c'est la petite victoire des borrels
prend aujourd'hui la lueur de symbole